[Music]
my name is Lovegrove I only know nine
loved groves two of which are my parents
they are first cousins and you know what
happens when you know so there's a
terribly weird freaky side to me which
I'm fighting with all the time so to try
and get through today I've kind of
disciplined myself with an 18-minute
talk I was hanging on to have a pee I
thought perhaps if I was hanging on long
enough that would that would guide me
through the 18 minutes okay I am known
as captain organic and that's a
philosophical position as well as a
aesthetic position but today what I'd
like to talk to you about is that love
of form and how form can touch people's
soul an emotion not very long ago not
many thousands of years and years ago we
actually lived in caves and I don't
think we've lost that coding system we
respond so well to form but I'm
interested in creating intelligent form
I'm not interested at all in blob ISM or
any of that superficial rubbish that you
see coming out as design these this
artificial we induce consumerism
I think it's atrocious my world is the
world of people like a Murray lovin
Janine Benyus James Watson I'm in that
world but I work purely instinctively
I'm not a scientist I could have been
perhaps but I work in this world where I
trust my instincts so I am a 21st
century translator of technology into
products that we use every day and
relate beautifully and naturally with
and we should be developing things we
should be developing packaging for ideas
which elevate people's perceptions
respect for the things that we dig out
of the earth and translate into products
for everyday use so the water bottle
I'll begin with this concept of what I
call DNA DNA design nature art these are
the three things that condition my world
here is a drawing by Leonardo da Vinci
500 years ago before photography it
shows how observation curiosity and
instinct work to create amazing art
industrial design is the art form of the
21st century people like Leonardo there
will have not been many had this
amazingly instinctive curiosity I work
from a similar position I don't sound
pretentious saying that but this is my
drawing made on a digital pad a couple
of years ago well into the 21st century
500 years later it's my impression of
water
Impressionism being the most valuable
art form on the planet as we know it a
hundred million dollars easily for money
I use now a whole new process a few
years ago I reinvented my process to
keep up with people like Greg Lynn Tom
Mane's our Hadid REM koolhaas all these
people that I think I'm persevering and
pioneering with fantastic new ideas of
how to create form this is all created
digitally here you see the machining the
milling of a block of acrylic this is
what I showed to the client to say
that's what I want to do at that point I
don't know if that's possible
at all it's a it's a Seductor but I just
feel in my bones that that's possible so
we go we look at the tooling we look at
how that is produced these are the
invisible things that you never see in
your life this is the background noise
of industrial design that is like an
Anish Kapoor flowing through a Richard
Serra it is more valuable than the
product in my eyes I don't have one when
I do make some money I'll have one
machine for myself this is the final
product when they send it to me I
thought I'd failed it felt like nothing
it has to feel like nothing it was when
I put the water in that I realized that
I put a skin on water itself it's an
icon of water itself and it elevates
people's perception of contemporary
design each bottle is different meaning
the water level will give you a
different shape its mass individualism
from a single
product it fits the hand it fits South's
Hritik hands if it's children's hands it
makes the product strong the tread
tessellation it's a meal FOIA of ideas
in the future they will look like that
because we need to move away from those
type of polymers and use that for
medical equipment and more important
things perhaps in life biopolymers these
new ideas for materials will come into
play and probably in a decade doesn't
look as cool doesn't but I can live up
to that I don't have a problem with that
I design for that condition biopolymers
it's the future I took this video in
Cape Town last year this is the freaky
site coming out I have this special
interest in things like this which blow
my mind I don't know whether to you know
drop to my knees cry I don't know what I
think but I just know that nature nature
improves with ever greater purpose that
way one that which once existed and that
strangeness is a consequence of
innovative thinking when I look at these
things they look pretty normal to me but
these things evolved over many years and
now what we're trying to do I get three
weeks to design a telephone how the hell
do I do a telephone three weeks when you
get these things that take hundreds of
million years to evolve how do you
condense that it comes back to instinct
I'm not talk about designing telephones
that look like that and I'm not looking
at designing architecture like that I'm
just interested in natural growth
patterns and the beautiful forms that
only nature really creates how that
flows through me and how that comes out
is what I'm trying to understand this is
a scan through the human forearm
it's then blown up through rapid
prototyping so reveal this cellular
structure I have these in my office my
office is a it's a mixture of the
Natural History Museum and a NASA Space
Lab it's a weird kind of freaky place
this is one of my specimens this is made
of bone is made from a mixture of energy
in argyll gallic inorganic minerals and
polymers i studied cooking in school for
four years and in that in that
experience which was called domestic
science it was a bit of a cheap trick
for me to try and get a science
qualification
actually I put marijuana in everything I
cooked and I had access to all the best
girls it was fabulous all the guys and
the rugby team couldn't understand that
anyway this is a meringue this is
another sample I have a meringue is made
exactly the same way in my estimation as
a bone
it's made from polysaccharides and
proteins
if you pour water on that it dissolves
could we be manufacturing from
foodstuffs in the future not a bad idea
I don't know I need to talk to Janine
and a few other people about that but I
believe instinctively that that meringue
can become something a car I don't know
I'm also interested in growth patterns
the unbridled way that nature grows
things so you're not restricted by form
at all these interrelate related forms
they do inspire everything I do although
I might end up making something
incredibly simple this is a detail of a
chair that I've designed in magnesium it
shows this interlocution
of elements and the beauty of kind of
engineering and biological thinking
shown pretty much is a bone structure
any one of those elements you could sort
of hang on the wall as some kind of art
object it's the world's first chair made
in magnesium cost 1.7 million dollars to
develop it's called go buy Banhart USA
it went into Time magazine in 2001 as
the new language of the 21st century boy
for somebody grown up in Wales in a
little village that's a that's enough
shows how you make one holistic form
like the car industry and then you break
up what you need this is an absolutely
beautiful way of working it's a godly
way of working there it's organic and
it's essential it's an absolutely
fat-free design and when you look at it
you see human beings being bless you
when that moves into polymers you can
change the elasticity the the fluidity
of the form this is an idea for a gas
injected one-piece polymer chair what
nature does is it drills holes in things
it liberates form it takes away anything
extraneous that's what I do I make
organic things which are essential I
don't and they look funky too but I
don't set out to make funky things
because I think that's an absolute
disgrace I set out to look at now
forms if you took the idea of fractal
technology further they take a membrane
shrinking it down constantly like nature
does that could be a seat for a chair it
could be a soul for sport shoe it could
be a car blending into seats well let's
go for it that's the kind of stuff this
is what exists in nature observation now
allows us to bring that natural process
into the design process
every day that's what I do this is a
show that's currently on in Tokyo it's
called super liquidity it's my
sculptural investigation
it's like 21st century Henry Moore when
you see a Henry Moore still your hair
stanza there's some amazing spiritual
connect if he was a car designer we'd
all be driving one in his day he was the
highest tax payer in Britain that is the
power of organic design it it
contributes immensely to sense of being
our sense of relationships of things
sensuality and you know the sort of even
them sort of socio erotic side which is
very important this is my artwork this
is all my process
these actually are sold as artwork
they're very big prints but this is how
I get to that object ironically that
object was made by the Killarney process
which is a brand new process here for
the 21st century and I can hear Greg
lend laughs and his socks off as I say
that I'll tell you about that later when
I look into these these data images I
see new things I'm self its self
inspired by atomic structures radiolaria
are the things that we couldn't see but
we can do now these again accord out
they're made virtually from nothing
they're made from silica why not
structures from cars like that coral all
these natural forces take away what they
don't need and they deliver maximum
beauty we need to be in that realm I
want to do stuff like that this is a new
chair which should come on the market in
September it's for a company called
Moroso and Italy it's a gas injected
polymer chair those holes you see there
are very filtered down watered down
version
the extremity of the diatomic structures
it goes with the flow of the polymer and
you see this is an image coming up right
now this shows the full thing it's great
to have companies in Italy who support
this way of dreaming if you see the
shadows that comes through that they're
actually probably more important than
the product but it's the minimum it
takes the coring out of the back lets
you breathe it takes away any material
you don't need and it actually Garner's
flexure too so kind of break into a
dance then the this is some current work
I'm doing I'm looking at single surface
structures and how they flow how they
stretch and flow it's based on furniture
topologies but that's not the and
motivate motivation it's made from
aluminum as opposed to aluminium and it
it's grown it's grown in my mind and
then it's grown in terms of the the
whole process that I go through this is
two weeks ago in CCP and Coventry who
build parts for Bentley's and so on it's
being built as we speak and beyond shelf
of in Philips next year in New York have
a big show at Philips your auctioneers I
when I see these animations Jesus I'm
blown away this is what goes on in my
studio every day I walk I'm traveling I
come back some guys got that on a
computer this oh my goodness so I tried
to create this energy of invention every
day in my studio this kind of
effervescent fully charged sense of soup
that delivers ideas single-surface
products furnishes a good one
how are you grow legs out of a surface I
would love to build this one day in
perhaps I'd like to build it also out of
flour sugar polymer woodchips I don't
know human hair I don't know I got a go
at that I don't know if I've just got
some time that's the way it's sight
coming out again and a lot of companies
don't understand that three weeks ago I
was with Sony and in Tokyo they said
give us the dream what is our dream how
do we be Apple I said well you don't
copy Apple that's for sure
I said you get into biopolymers they
looked straight through me what a waste
anyway
that's true you know I mean
now I'm delivering
they're not taking I've had this image
20 years I've had this image of a water
droplet for 20 years sitting on a hot
bed that is an image of a car for me
that's the car of the future it's a
water droplet I've been banging on about
this I can't believe cars are all wrong
I'm going to show you something a bit
weird now
they laughed everywhere over the world I
showed this the only place didn't laugh
was Moscow its cars are made from 30,000
components how ridiculous is that
couldn't you make that from 300 it's got
a vacuum formed carbon nylon pan
everything's holistically integrated it
opens and closes like a bread bin there
is no engine there's a solar panel on
the back and there are batteries in the
wheels that fitted like Formula one you
take them off you Ollie plug them in off
you jolly well go a three-wheeled car
slow feminine transparent so you can see
the people in there you drive different
you see that thing you do you do and not
anesthetized separated from life there's
a hole at the front and that there's a
reason for that
it's a city car you drive along you get
out you drop you're on you drive on to
probiscus you get out it lifts you up it
presents the solar panel to the Sun and
at night it's the street lamp that's
what happens if you get inspired by the
street lamp first and then did the car
second these bubbles I can see these
bubbles with these hydrogen packages
floating around on the ground driven by
a I when I showed this in South Africa
everybody after was going here hey car
on a stick like this can you imagine
careless dick if you put it next to
contemporary architecture feels totally
natural to me and that's what I do with
my furniture
I'm not putting Charles Eames furniture
in buildings anymore forget that we move
on I'm trying to build furniture which
fits architecture I'm trying to build
transportation systems I work on
aircraft for Airbus the whole thing I do
all this sort of stuff trying to force
these natural inspired by nature dreams
home I'm gonna finish on two things this
is the stereo lithography of a staircase
it's a little bit of a dedication to
James James Watson
I built this thing for my studio cost me
$250,000 to build this
most people go and buy the aston martin
i built this this is the data that goes
with that incredibly complex took about
two years because I'm looking for fat
free design lean efficient things
healthy products yeah this is built by
composites it's a single element which
rotates round to create a holistic
element and this is a carbon fiber Ham
rail which is only supported in two
places modern materials allow us to do
modern things this is a shot in the
studio this is how it looks pretty much
everyday you you wouldn't want to have
her fear of heights coming down it there
is virtually no handrail doesn't pass
any standards who cares yeah and it has
an internal handrail which gives it its
strength it's this holistic integration
that's my studio its subterranean it's
in Notting Hill next to all the crap by
the prostitutes all that stuff it's next
to David Hockney's original studio it
has a lighting system that changed it
out the day my guys go out for lunch the
doors open they come back in because
it's normally raining and they prefer to
stay this is my studio
elephant skull from Oxford University
1988 I thought that last year they're
very difficult to find if anybody's got
a whale skeleton they want to sell me
I'll put it in studio so I'm just gonna
intersect interject a little bit with
some of the things that you'll see in
the video it's a home made video made it
myself three o'clock in the morning just
to show you how my real world is you
never see that you never see architects
or designers showing you their real
world this is called a plasma it's a
poly carpet a bio polycarbonate new
chairman Italy world's first bamboo bike
with folding handlebars we should all be
riding one of these as China buys all
these crappy cars we should be writing
things like this counterbalance like I
say it's a cross between Natural History
Museum and a NASA laboratory
it's full of prototypes and objects it's
self inspirational again I mean the rare
times when I'm there I do enjoy it and I
get lots of kids coming lots and lots of
kids coming I'm a contaminator for all
those children of investment bankers
wankers this sorry success
that's the solar seed it's a concept for
new architecture that thing on the top
is the world's first solar-powered
garden lamp the first produced Giles
Revell should be talking here today
amazing photography of things you can't
see the first sculptural model I made
for that thing in Tokyo
lots of stuff visit a leaf chair that
golden looking thing is called leaf it's
made from Kevlar on the wall is my book
called supernatural which allows me to
remember what I've done because I forget
there's an aerated brick I did in
Limoges last year concepts new ceramics
in architecture yeah not over fell
working at 3 o'clock in the morning and
I don't pay overtime all the time is the
passion of design so hey
join the club or done that's true so
people like Tom and Greg will traveling
like you got we fit it all in I don't
know we did next week I'm at Electrolux
in Sweden then I'm in Beijing on Friday
you work that one out and when I see
Ed's photographs I think why the hell am
I going to China it's true there's this
soul in this whole thing we need to have
a new instinct for the 21st century we
need to combine all this stuff if all
the people who are talking over this
period worked on a car together it would
be a joy absolute joy
so there's a new X light system I'm
doing in Japan there's a Tuareg shoes
from North Africa as a quick wave damask
these are my sculptures a cup of jelly
mold sounds like some quiz show or
something you know what that's gonna end
thank you James for your great
inspiration thank you very much
[Applause]
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance or
held no value there is a place where
artistic vision is protected where
inspired design ideas live on to become
ultimate driving machines
[Music]
you